hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the conclusion
to her work the second sex Simone de
Beauvoir is going to raise the question
why does it seem inevitable that there
has to be a battle of the sexes why
can't humans divided into men and women
come to terms with each other in good
faith and the answer to this is going to
come out of her existentialist
philosophy and her diagnosis a bit of
double-dealing as she's going to call it
a bit of duplicity going on with both
sides both the male side and the female
side keeping them from being able to
have some genuine recognition of each
other first though before discussing
that she raises the question and she's
doing sort of a survey of the ground
that she's covered she says that we've
seen that in spite of Legends no
physiological destiny imposes an eternal
hostility upon male and female as such
so it's not our biology that's
determining us to be stuck in this this
quandary biology matters male and female
are different and they are connected to
each other through
reproduction and they are different from
each other in ways that they don't fully
understand in which which introduced
imbalances but that's not the end of the
story and anybody who pretends that
somehow biology determines everything is
really operating in bad faith so she
goes on and she says Humanity is
something more than a mere species it is
a historical development it is to be
defined by the manner in which it deals
with its natural fixed characteristics
its facticity
and that's a French term that we often
translate just as facticity and that's a
term that's particularly important
within existentialist ethics it means
the things that we're stuck with so for
example my appearance or my maleness or
my age in this case which I'm not
actually stuck with all that long
because I'm gonna be older later but I'm
never gonna be young again right unless
on there there's some sort of sci-fi
thing going on all of that is part of
our facticity and our facticity for an
existentialist does not determine us we
are working within the structures of
that facticity but it doesn't provide
you could say the absolute last word on
how things are going to go so she says
even with the most extreme bad faith in
the world it's impossible to demonstrate
the existence of a rivalry between the
human male and female of a truly
physiological nature so if we reject
that where do we go next because we do
seem to have this opposition and
long-term hostility going on she says
maybe their hostility could be allocated
to that intermediate terrain between
biology and psychology psychoanalysis
woman were told envies man his penis and
wishes to castrate him but the childish
desire for the penis is important in the
life of the adult woman only if she
feels her femininity as a mutilation
which Freud seemed to take for granted
but plenty of you know women and also
female psychoanalyst have come along and
said
maybe you're wrong about that part of
the theory maybe you're extrapolating
too much here and so that's being
rejected as well she says that you know
maybe it's just a symbol of all the
privileges of manhood that she wishes to
appropriate when when we're talking
about the phallus or the penis or
whatever right
any sort of envy would not be of having
a biological part but rather of having
the functions that go along with it
so if that's not introducing some sort
of inevitable hostility maybe we have to
look elsewhere as de pouvoir points out
her desire the woman's desire is much
more ambiguous she wishes in a
contradictory fashion to have this
transcendence that the male is accorded
which is to suppose that she at once
respects it and denies it that she
intends at once to throw herself into it
and keep it within herself and then she
says this is to say the drama does not
unfold on a sexual level further
sexuality has never seemed to us to
define a destiny to furnish in itself
the key to human behavior
so sexuality is just one part of a much
more complex picture for de Beauvoir and
all of these psychological or
psychoanalytic or whatever other
theories we want to bring to bear on
this are really skirting for her around
the set of the central issue which is
that males are accorded a kind of
transcendence that females are not being
granted females are being pushed back
into imminence and she highlights this
in many different ways throughout the
work so she goes on and says what does
sexuality do it expresses the totality
of a situation that it only helps to
define what is that totality what is
that situation here is where she comes
to discuss efforts at some sort of
getting past this or compensating for it
and then she'll talk about the duplicity
or double-dealing that's taking place so
she says that this titanic conflict
assumes on earth two two totally
different forms corresponding with two
different moments of history in the
earlier moment woman is forced into
imminence that is woman is being treated
as an object albeit a certain kind of
object one that can provide recognition
to the subject which is male which is
allowed transcendence there may be some
rare occasions or there may be some
exceptions of that woman who's able to
achieve transcendence but it's against a
backdrop of many other women who are
treated as if they are not fully human
as being not even second-class citizens
because they're often not even citizens
are they so she says the woman who is
shut up in imminence endeavors to hold
man in that prison also thus the prison
will be confused with the world and the
woman will no longer suffer but from
being confined there what does she mean
by this so a woman who has become
objectified or Ray Fi turned into a
living object or if we want to use
Aristotle's sort of framework we could
say an insult tool that's what he uses
of the slave but we could just as well
use that of woman in this case being
forced into being treated like a thing
having all of her being there in say the
roles that de Beauvoir is going to talk
about like motherhood
there's an attempt to try to bring then
the male into that and say well you're
an object too you are just my son
you are just my lover or you are just
whatever it happens to be so she gives
some examples she says mother wife
sweetheart are the jailers society being
codified by man decrees women as
inferior she can do away with his
inferiority only by destroying the may
superiority so she pulls him down to
that level
she says she sucks about mutilating him
dominating him contradicting him denying
his truth and his value then she goes on
she says in doing this she's only
defending herself it was neither a
changeless essence nor a mistaken choice
that doomed her to eminence to
inferiority these were imposed upon her
so what we have in that case is a kind
of tragic situation and if you think
about the ways in which she's framing
this many relationships have indeed
followed this sort of course that she is
setting out and neither person winds up
being happy as a result is there another
possibility there certainly is
she talks about woman emerging into
transcendence and this is what you know
the feminist movement of her time she
sees leading to but that's not gonna
bring about a complete resolution either
why because it's not actually going to
resolve all of the issues she says today
the combat takes a different shape
instead of wishing to put man in a
prison instead of pulling him down
woman endeavors to escape from one she
no longer seeks to drag him into the
realms of imminence but to emerge
herself into the light of transcendence
but this is a problem not because
there's anything wrong with emerging
into transcendence but the attitude of
the males creates a new conflict it's
with a bad grace that he lets her go
there's going to be a lot of resistance
to this and we see this in myriad forms
even in our own society today where
women quite often are not allowed to
have the same sort of agency as men do
and are ignored not listened to right
she goes on and she says how does the
woman responds she replies to his lack
of confident by assuming an aggressive
attitude it's no longer a question of
individuals each shut up in their
spheres a caste claiming its rights goes
over the top and is resisted by the
privileged caste so here we have to
transcendence --is face to face
instead of displaying mutual recognition
each free being wishes to dominate the
other the women who are seeking the
transcendence that men have been granted
emerge into transcendence largely
bootstrapping themselves or relying upon
previous efforts of other women and
perhaps allies among men men and women
confront each other as to transcendence
'as rather than attempting to come to
some sort of terms with each other they
spar they turn things into a zero-sum
game so to speak and here is where de
Beauvoir will talk about a certain kind
of double-dealing or duplicity going on
on both sides here's what she says many
women in order to show by their
successes their equivalents to men try
to secure male support by sexual means
in this sense they are playing on both
sides demanding old-fashioned respect
and modern esteem banking on their old
magic and their new rights this doesn't
mean that women are all sleeping with
men in order to you know get some sort
of temporary advantage out of this but
they might use attractiveness in some
sense they might use a sense of chivalry
right and and this is what throws a lot
of men not just in to move ours time but
in our own time for a bit of a loop
because there will be some
double-dealing it's not quite clear
where you stand are are we actually
equals that's what modern esteem would
imply or are we back in this position
where a woman can tell a man man up you
need to grow a pair of balls you need to
do this and that in order to benefit me
but the man is not able to are not
allowed to say something similar like
why don't you woman up right we don't
have a phrase like that in our in our
culture in our lexicon and so there's a
double-dealing going on correlative lis
men are also double-dealing
according to the waar and you know as
the ones who are in a privileged
position they're double dealing perhaps
bears a bit more scrutiny and a bit more
responsibility and criticism because
what are men doing he says that if she
says that here we go man is also
double-dealing when he requires women to
play the game fairly while he denies
them the indispensable trump cards
through distrust and hostility men might
say oh we're all equal now in the
workplace or we're all equal in academia
or we're all equal in the family are all
equal in this respect but I am NOT gonna
treat you as if you're completely equal
I'm gonna treat you with a kind of
distrust or suspicion and hostility I'll
denigrate the things that you do I won't
count them as worth as much and we might
also add to this a sort of sense of
entitlement you might think of a man who
says yes we share the housework equally
but then when you actually look at it
you notice that she's doing most of the
take the caretaking of the kids right
that just doesn't count as housework
right because it's not cleaning up or
something like that and we could go on
and on and on now both of these
reinforce each other and both of them
allow the other one to say well if
they're not going to be completely fair
if they're gonna be double-dealing I
have to hold on to my advantage and this
leads to another sort of tragic
situation de Beauvoir talks about this
in great length she says women is opaque
in her very being she stands before a
man not as the subject but an object
paradoxically endued with subjectivity
she takes herself simultaneously as self
and as an other a contradiction that
entails baffling consequences when she
makes weapons at once of her weakness
and of her strength it is not a matter
of designing calculation this has been
imposed upon her right at the same time
when she is actively demanding her
sovereignty and no doubt this procedures
unfair
dicks but it's dictated by the ambiguous
situation assigned her man becomes
indignant when he treats her as a free
and independent being and realizes she
is still a trap for him bringing her
bringing him into her imminence if he
gratifies and satisfies her in her
posture as prey he finds her claims to
autonomy irritating whatever he does he
feels tricked and she feels wronged
that's a very good way of framing it he
feels tricked she feels wronged and we
could easily change those polarities as
well
the woman could feel tricked she did the
things that she ought to do and she's
still not being treated as an equal man
can also feel wronged those women are
crossing certain boundaries that
fairness and justice requires and then
we get the situation that she's going to
describe here's how she frames it the
quarrel will go on as long as men and
women fail to recognize each other as
peers as equals
and not equals just in a formal sense
but equals in the sense a Hegelian sense
of needing to give each other
recognition there has to be a
reciprocity there a recognition of the
other as a genuine self not just merely
as another as another self and the
boudoir closes this section with a very
interesting proposal she says that is to
say as long as femininity is perpetuated
as such which sex is the most eager to
maintain it women who is emancipated
from it wishes nonetheless to retain its
privileges and man in that case wants
her to assume its limitations now notice
that she's not saying femininity has to
be gotten rid of entirely but it has to
be rethought if there's going to be some
impasse beyond this battle of the sexes
and that's not just a matter of women
having to read
think it but also of men having to
rethink it and they have to work out and
negotiate a solution that can be
acceptable to both sides and pave the
way for getting past this sort of
double-dealing
you